um can you give for people who are
watching this who want to get involved
in making original content or maybe they
want to try to figure out how to get an
idea they have for a TV show going or
something like that but maybe they not
might not necessarily have the
relationships the resources whatever it
is what would be some advice you would
give them don't stop I mean to
think about like everybody can do all of
this literally from their phone uh
that's even one of the reasons why I'm
excited about launching a daily Cannon
because it's like it's literally from
your phone if need be like the fact you
can make millions of dollars from your
phone so there's no more excuses back in
the day I used to have to shoot pilots
and rent cameras and say all of that
stuff to to just to get my ideas out now
you can do the same level of content
from your phone like if like if you
listen to DC Young Fly story man he was
young he didn't even have a phone he had
to steal somebody's phone and make the
content to you know now do as a
millionaire in a household name so it's
like there are no excuses you could do
it from the trap you could do it from
your projects you could do you know the
Homie watomi Quan he's like dude I do
everything on my phone everything you
see is edited on my iPhone these are the
two apps I use there's no way it's only
one you know that was somebody you know
I saw his movement we gave my
opportunity on Wildland out so I was
like there's no excuses out there uh
talk about the new radio show Daily
Cannon man it's a new platform it's on
AMP yeah yeah yeah so which is owned by
Amazon it's owned by Amazon so we we
over there cooking uh but it's like it's
beauty is Reinventing radio and kind of
bringing social media and podcasting all
into the same form so it's it's dope
because in the same way like I'm always
I remember when Twitter first popped on
I remember when Tick Tock was musically
I was in there and like I feel like I
feel like the same Buzz uh is going on
now with with uh these ideas of like
community and we've seen it pop with
Clubhouse but I feel like amp is even
taken to another level because now
you're allowed to have your own show in
your own content right and your own
brand right and they're empowering you
like through the system of Amazon so you
know it's no more talking at people it's
talking with people so everybody can
have a show everybody can have listeners
so that's how we rocking you know Monday
through Friday 6 a.m to 9 A.M so you're
doing that Monday through Friday six to
nine live live what the [__] and this is
with Abby yeah yeah she's gonna be on
there too so shout out to Abby DJ Abby
De la Rosa she playing music yeah oh so
she's playing music you're hosting yeah
yeah she's part of the show too but you
gotta have her talk with that random
voice yeah yeah now she's up but she she
runs she's the musical director as well
so she's she's getting it in yeah shout
out to Abby for people who don't know
your uh two two of your kids oh she had
twins yeah yeah yeah she she been on
radio for a long time yeah started with
young Cowboys she was a star before
before the candy yeah it's not like you
were like yo let me put my baby mama on
yeah she she's a master in this space if
anything I need her more than she needs
me in this space so that's six to nine
wilding out then the new show with Kevin
Hart where you're you're pretty much
it's kind of like filling a space that
has been vacated for a very long time
because back in the day we had punked
yeah before that Candid Camera uh
celebrity bloopers and practical jokes
and all that stuff but now we just did
it you know everybody know me Kevin ever
since we got money we started playing
pranks on each other right uh and you
know that's what rich friends do to each
other so we wanted to be like yo we
could we should turn this into a TV show
and let the world in on it because I
mean we were doing it through social
media already but now it's a number one
show on E yo you mentioned you being
rich you have all the money uh you don't
leave no money for nobody else
now I'm at the stage in my life where
I'm trying to get everybody else it's
it's Lonely at the Top baby like I want
my friends to be rich too so that's
always been the concept so now I'm at
the stage it ain't I don't care about
making money no more I want some
Financial friends and family financial
literacy advice from Nick Cannon yes
give me give me a few gems listen I've
had lots of babies and instead of giving
them the money create trust in their
name so by the time they're 18 years old
they're CEOs of their own company and it
could be whatever the company they want
to be and you finance it so now you
birth the business and also isn't there
some sort of like account that you can
put a certain amount of money in for
each kid it's a tax write-off every year
well that don't [__] with the IRS we
ain't trying to get no tax write-offs I
give all my money to where it's supposed
to be you pay taxes yeah absolutely but
you're too rich to be paying no but see
what it is you got to understand you
gotta have your tax money make money but
we'll get into that in another
conversation but I'll give the
government everything they ask for your
tax money make money yes so you you
again I give the government everything
they ask for I just really I get audited
like Nick I'm sorry listen Nick I'm
starting to do pretty good right now so
yeah I really just need some advice not
to be like I mean honestly that that's
don't ever play with the IRS oh I'm not
trying to do it that's the best guy
loopholes yeah no [__] that okay because
that's where they go you see the the
biggest gangsters in the world what
they're in prison for tax evasion
exactly so shout out to Wesley sniper do
not play like give them the money that
they asked for but learn how to how to
get your money and operate and give them
everything that they need but there's
ways to actually if you're a wise
businessman if you got good business man
there's like there's stuff in the tax
code you can take advantage of yeah but
see like I may I know not to get into
like I make so much money that like all
of that that concept of oh or tax
write-offs that's only for when you when
you're in a certain level when you make
more when you pay more in taxes than
most people make in a lifetime I just
you always hear how like Jeff Bezos
doesn't pay taxes stuff but that's what
I see that yeah that's not what they so
what they're saying is there's
infrastructure set up I'll give you a
part perfect example like um and that's
just probably gonna get a little too
deep but when you get into like the
world of like lobbyists and in the world
of like even non-profits in that sense
to where there's levels you can give an
abundant amount of money to things that
you really care about and it and and you
would rather do that than give it to the
IRS yeah or and that's legal yeah it's
you can give you can have uh charitable
for philanthropic efforts where you can
give hundreds of millions of dollars
away to education to child care to uh
and you would rather do that than give
it to them yeah because and and you're
saying that's not illegal you're saying
hey government let me do what you're
doing right you know what I mean it's
almost like you would rather spend your
tax money on stuff that you care about
exactly so who what lobbyists is Nick
Cannonball what are we lobbying for Nick
well let's see that's where you know I
feel like nobody knows where you are on
the political Spectrum
yeah that's how it should be you're Nick
Cannon you're like an enigma yeah I was
like you know I'll let them live how
they want to live